I'd like to finish off by sharing with you
two quite amazing research videos they both
show the power of combining visual information
taken from multiple viewpoints.
The first is a system that draws large depositories
of photographs, for instance, Flickr. In this
case they retrieve a whole lot of images taken
of Rome.
All of these images taken by different people
at different times clearly have a lot of overlap.
What they do is they find the same points
in multiple images and from that then, they
can then reconstruct the relative precision
of the cameras that took those pictures.
Then they can combine this information across
hundreds or even thousands of pictures and
use that to reconstruct a full three-dimensional
model.
They didn't have to go and visit, they just
mined the web for photographs that were already
there, and with some very clever algorithms
were able to extract from all those pictures,
this three dimensional model.
This next one extends the technique to combine
information from millions and millions of
images taken by different people with different cameras at different times but of the same subject matter.